>>> A CLOSER LOOK AT THE LANDS
MARK CLIMATE INVESTMENTS IN THIS
NEW DEMOCRATIC PLAN.
$369 BILLION IN NEW CLIMATE
SPENDING.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS THE IMPACT
SHOULD HELP THE UNITED STATES
CUT ITS GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
BY HALF BY THE END OF THIS
DECADE.
HOW WILL THAT HAPPEN AND WHAT
DOES IT MEAN FOR YOU?
LET'S DISCUSS WITH THE WHITE
HOUSE NATIONAL CLIMATE ADVISOR,
GINA McCARTHY.
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
$369 BILLION IN NEW CLIMATE
SPENDING.
THAT WILL GET YOU A STANDING
OVATION AT DAVOS.
WHAT DOES IT DO FOR THE AVERAGE
FAMILY WHERE I GREW UP IN
DORCHESTER?
>> WELL, JOHN, YOU AND I KNOW
DORCHESTER WELL.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S GOING TO DO?
IT'S GOING TO SAVE THOSE
FAMILIES WHO LIVE IN DORCHESTER
MONEY.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES HERE, NOT JUST FOR
FAMILIES TO SAVE MONEY BUT ALSO
TO ADVANCE THAT JOB GROWTH HERE,
TO PROVIDE STABILITY, ENERGY
RELIABILITY AND SECURITY.
THIS IS A WAY FOR US TO EXPAND
DOMESTIC PRODUCTION,
MANUFACTURING IN THE UNITED
STATES AGAIN, OF ALL THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND PRODUCTS.
THIS IS REALLY QUITE GROUND
BREAKING, IN FACT I'D CALL IT
HISTORIC.
WHETHER IT'S AS BIG AS 2004 FOR
THE RED SOX OR NOT WE CAN
DEBATE, BUT THIS IS PRETTY
AMAZING OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
UNITED STATES TO LEAD AGAIN IN
CLIMATE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, TO REALLY
SERVE THE PEOPLE HERE.
THIS IS WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
VISION HAS ALWAYS BEEN.
IT'S ALL ABOUT PEOPLE AND MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE BENEFIT FROM
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
PEOPLE, LABOR, WORKERS.
THIS IS WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT.
THIS IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
>> SO LET'S WALK THROUGH SOME OF
THE PARTICULARS.
$NEARLY $400 BILLION IN TAX
CREDITS FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES
AND UTILITIES.
TACK CREDITS FOR HEAT PUMPS,
ROOFTOP SOLAR, WATER HEATERS.
IT FORCES OIL AND GAS COMPANIES
TO PAY FEES FOR METHANE RELEASE.
HELP ME GET TO THE STREET HERE.
YOU DO KNOW DORCHESTER WELL.
HOW DO YOU CHANGE THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE IN A
PLACE LIKE THAT?
PEOPLE PARK IN THE STREET, THEY
DON'T HAVE A GARAGE.
HOW DOES THIS BILL CHANGE THE
WAY AMERICA LOOKS WHEN IT COMES
TO MOVING TO A GREENER, ELECTRIC
ECONOMY, ESPECIALLY IN
TRANSPORTATION?
>> LOOK, EVERYBODY, INCLUDING
THE FOLKS IN DORCHESTER, NEED TO
KNOW THAT EVERY PENNY THEY SPEND
IS WELL SPENT.
THEY'RE GOING TO WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE BEST APPLIANCES
THAT ARE ENERGY EFFICIENT.
THEY WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
ROOFTOP SOLAR.
THEY'RE GOING TO WANT TO KNOW
THAT WE'RE PROTECTING THEM
THROUGH ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE SO THAT THEY CAN FEEL
THAT THE SEA IS NOT GOING TO
ENCROACH ON THEM AGAIN.
THEY'RE GOING TO WANT TO KNOW
THAT WE'RE SPENDING MONEY IN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT $60 BILLION
HERE ADDED TO $60 BILLION IN THE
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE LAW TO
GET TO THE COMMUNITIES LEFT
BEHIND, TO TACKLE LEGACY
POLLUTION, TO INVEST IN OUR
SCHOOLS AGAIN, TO GET RID OF THE
OLD HEAVY DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS AND
BUSES THAT HAVE CONTAMINATED OUR
AIR IN OUR URBAN AREAS.
BUT IT'S ALSO FOR THE AREAS THAT
YOU AND I HAVEN'T WELL TRAVELED,
AT LEAST I HAVEN'T.
IT'S THE FARMING COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE URBAN
AREAS.
THIS IS ABOUT OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
THEY NEED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
THEY NEED OPPORTUNITIES FOR NEW
FARMING TECHNIQUES.
THEY NEED OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY CAN PRODUCE OUR
FOOD, BUT ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE TACKLING THE DROUGHT SO
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
ALL IN ONE.
SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY NOT
JUST FOR THE DORCHESTERS OF THE
WORLD BUT THE IOWAS OF THE
WORLD.
WE KNOW THAT WIND IS WILD IN
IOWA, THEY'RE CAPTURING.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT CLEAN
ENERGY IS THE FUTURE.
THE REAL QUESTION IS, WHO'S
GOING TO BUILD IT, WHO'S GOING
TO PRODUCE THOSE PRODUCTS, AND
WHO'S GOING TO LEAD THE WORLD.
THIS BILL IS TELLING YOU THE
ANSWER TO THOSE THREE QUESTIONS
IS THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
OUR WORKERS, OUR FAMILIES ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE GOING TO
BENEFIT.
>> AS YOU KNOW, THESE GIANT
POLICY CHANGES BEING CONSIDERED,
WE'RE 94 DAYS AWAY FROM A VERY
BIG MIDTERM ELECTION AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL DECIDE
WHICH PARTY CONTROLS CONGRESS
COME NOVEMBER.
THE MAN WHO HOPES TO BE MAJORITY
LEADER IN THE SENATE, MITCH
McCONNELL, SAYS THIS IS A
GIVEAWAY.
LISTEN.
>> DEMOCRATS HAVE ALREADY ROBBED
AMERICAN FAMILIES ONCE THROUGH
INFLATION AND NOW THEIR SOLUTION
IS TO ROB AMERICAN FAMILIES YET
A SECOND TIME.
JACKING UP AMERICANS'
ELECTRICITY BILLS AND GAS PRICES
IN ORDER TO SUBSIDIZE RICH
PEOPLE BUYING LUXURY CARS AND
NEW APPLIANCES WILL NOT MAKE ONE
DENT IN THE FUTURE TRAJECTORY OF
GLOBAL TEMPERATURES.
>> IS HE RIGHT?
>> NO.
AND MY HOPE IS HE'LL TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT THE BILL.
BECAUSE EVEN THE CLEAN CAR
INITIATIVE IS LOOKING AT BEING
EXCLUSIVELY LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME FAMILIES.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT FOLKS WHO
ARE WEALTHIER WILL BE ABLE TO
AFFORD IT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THIS BILL
IS FOR EVERYONE AND LEAVES NO
COMMUNITY BEHIND.
IT IS CALLED THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT FOR A REASON, AND
YOU CAN GO CALL ALL THOSE NOBEL
PRIZE WINNER ECONOMIC PEOPLE
INSTEAD OF ME AND THEY'LL TELL
YOU THAT THIS BILL IS GOING TO
SAVE OUR FAMILIES MONEY ALL
ACROSS THE BOARD.
BUT LOOK, RIGHT BEFORE WE
TALKED, I MEAN WE WERE LOOKING
AT SOME HEARTBREAKING NEWS IN
KENTUCKY.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE LOOKING AT
EVERYWHERE IN THE UNITED STATES
AND FRANKLY ACROSS THE WORLD
BEING IMPACTED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE.
NOW IS THE TIME TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS.
AND IF WE CAN DO THIS, NOT
SACRIFICING BUT ACTUALLY
BUILDING A STRONGER ECONOMY,
INCREASING OUR WORKFORCE, AS
THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE, USE HIS
VISION THAT IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE,
NOT THE PLANET, THEN WE WILL
ACTUALLY PROVIDE THE KIND OF
FUTURE FOR OUR KIDS THAT WE
WANT, BUT DO IT TODAY, WITH THE
TECHNOLOGIES OF TODAY AND THE
INNOVATIONS OF THE FUTURE.
THIS IS AN EXCITING MOMENT IN
TIME, JOHN, AND I DON'T --
ACTUALLY AM NOT GOING TO LISTEN
TO ANYBODY THAT DISSUADES ME
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN IT, I'VE LIVED
IT FOR 30 YEARS PUSHING FOR THIS
BILL.
IT IS SECOND TO NONE IN TERMS OF
ITS BREADTH OF CHANGE THAT IT
PROMISES AND WILL DELIVER.